and the way that you can do that and
expand their mindset so that they are
not just stuck within the four walls
either of their house or their community
and they can see beyond that is helping
them discover
whether that's from home virtually or
whether that's actually traveling
[Music]
alexa maria ralph bone barker how are
you i'm good thanks how are you
did i get the full name right yeah you
did that that's the most important
question
good so we rehearsed a bit and like i
mentioned it was like the addiction
exercises
i think i might even just use that on a
daily basis now but but it's
a fantastic name even an even better
name is the name of your company tripa
brood
which also really rolls off the tongue
and i just love so we have
a lot to talk about all the way from
your financial times with bloomberg
and now to triple brood to your own
personal experiences with the challenges
of family travel
to now solving it for a lot of others
but really you know the whole industry
is a fascinating one especially in 2021
and we have an opportunity here to be
almost like sort of like hypothesized
prophets and and what's going to happen
and as you're dealing with this on a
daily basis so before we do all that
you go to cuba in 2008 talk to me about
your
own sort of history and what that trip
was for you because i always loved
starting with a fun fact
yeah yeah so you asked me a great
question little known fact about me well
i'm
i'm half cuban uh so my mom was born in
cuba
my granddad was very senior in the
american government within cuba and um
they were exiled in 1960 as were many
cubans
and uh were welcomed into america um
and uh ever since i was born uh we'd
always had
you know that was that was a challenge
um and i became the first family member
to go back in
in 2008 with my husband and
um it's hard to describe it it was like
that feeling of when you
you haven't discovered half of you and
there's things that you don't know
why you do certain things by your
reaction ways
um and then you go somewhere and it's
like being plugged into an electric
socket for me
arriving at cuba and traveling around
cuba was actually like
um becoming alive and um
it was the most incredible experience
and we revisited the old family home
uh we yeah kind of stepped into where my
grandparents
uh were married the church wow and it
was
um it was supernova and we were kind of
sending at that time
you know sending photos was a challenge
so we were then came back and created
some like photo books for the family and
it was the first time since they left
cuba they could see
the old road the old town the coffee
plantation
all of that sort of stuff so it was um
it was incredible but um
yeah i think having having that sort of
culture where i know that i'm half
english and half cuban two very very
different cultures for me
has always been i've always been a bit
eccentric and a bit different
and uh it was great to realize why
i'm unbelievable so um i'd like somebody
i really want to
talk about that your experience with the
bloomberg but even more than that right
now
i'm i'm really excited to spend some
some meaningful time talking about
travel talking about the trooper brood
before we talk about you know covet 19
and the industry of travel
you're making a clear distinction
between you know our personal travel our
business travel and
family travel why are they different
yeah yeah no great question i think um
that distinction is something that
hasn't really been made
in the industry and to such a degree
before right these have sort of been
bucketed into
travelers and when you go on an online
travel agent yep
it's a one-size-fits-all model doesn't
matter who you are where you come from
you ask the three questions where are
you going where are you going with whom
and then you get the list of options
that you draw through um
the challenge with families is the
complexity of traveling with children
the fact that you've got different ages
you've got different desires you've got
competing interests
you've got what the adults want you've
got what the children want then as the
children grow
up those needs and wants change and as a
parent i have never been a parent of an
eight-year-old before
my child becomes eight but my
understanding of what an eight-year-old
can do
is completely fresh and uh and so the
amount of time it takes
parents to work out what is the most
suitable holiday for their
family needs takes an extremely long
time on average about 30 hours of
research pure research time to get to a
point
really 30 hours that's on average
wow and is that because is that because
of the
you know i'm guessing it's not because
of the you know the clashing
personalities and every person wants to
do something else but it's also because
of you know
accessibility issues and you need to
make sure that you have a place that is
both suitable for
a toddler and a teenager and put you
know a
first grader and something that that the
two
parents can potentially even enjoy if
they if they can allow that for that
trip
so so what's been happening today what
are some what are some existing you know
solutions that people have offered and
and what is sort of the inspiration and
motivation for starting trip approved
yeah so at the moment what has happened
is that
parents have um overweighted
uh coping mechanisms to help them make
that decision which is essentially a
compromised decision
because as you as you point out there is
nowhere perfect
for parents with a teenager with a
toddler
maybe a five-year-old it's all about
what are the things that i'm willing to
compromise on or what are the things i'm
not willing to compromise on it's that
mental arithmetic of actually this
right seems to fit the most things
and i feel like that probably would be a
good thing for me to go to
and what parents have had to layer in a
lot of is
parents like me recommendations so uh
if i speak to a parent i think they're
like me they've got a similar family
makeup
if they liked it i'm probably gonna like
it too
so parents have gone down that road
they've gone down
is if i've been somewhere before and
it's worked i'm gonna go back
again and again because i kind of
guarantee myself
a good stay now that's that's a positive
because you know you're going to have a
good experience it's a negative as well
because you repeat the same thing
year after year and then you've got a
third bracket of parents
who have given up on holidaying entirely
basically say
you know we're not going to go on family
holidays until our kids are older
and these were these three buckets of
people that i found as i taught around
the country and started you know
fleshing this out idea out and it kind
of goes to
why i found a triple breed which was
from my own personal experiences as a
month of three
when i was working at bloomberg and
researching
a particular family holiday we were
going back to hong kong and i had run
the hong kong office for
bloomberg and we were taking back off
her child um
and i spent six weeks um and i counted
the time
on my commute back and forth into london
researching
a hotel with a room that fit five people
uh in hong kong island with a swimming
pool that was my criteria full stop
it took me six weeks wow one place and
then at the point of booking they turned
around and said
it's going to be 500 extra for a cop bed
for your son
and um at that stage airbnb
self-catered i didn't want to self-cater
but it was that aha moment of having
you know i i've worked in an industry
where
complex data sets is just a given but
what is also a given
is that um the customer in our case
in bloomberg it was the financial
professional has an easy way to
understand complex data and that's our
job that was our job at bloomberg to
translate data into a meaningful way
that
financial professionals could make
financial decisions and yet i looked at
the online travel industry
i thought there's all this data there's
all this information
and yet it's not there's no way for me
to understand with all of this
information what is right for me
and my personal needs right i think that
two things that he said before by the
way
that are particularly interesting for me
because i i always
you know i spend most of my time when i
when i when i talk to startups
think about the problem and really
identifying the pain point and how does
the customer behavior has
potentially shifted and i think that
that's what you're outlined here is that
the customer behavior shifted in two
very
very important ways and and it's
differentiated in two important ways one
is that
you know unlike most travelers if you
ask the average you know young
traveler or the single traveler what is
their priority
it probably would also be to to
experience something new
right to go somewhere they they haven't
been before to experience a new culture
new
new whatever and yet you're saying here
that we have this whole
cohort of people this whole population
that that is the last thing they want
when they find something that works they
want to stick to it because that
guarantees them
another great stay and you know now
thinking of all you know the young
families that i'm that i'm
saying it makes perfect sense i can
definitely see why that is a priority
and the other priority is you know some
people like to wander often
and you know not plan ahead and just
explore and experience
what you're saying here no we plan ahead
and we actually take
advice from others so strongly because
if somebody else is
that has a family that is similar to my
demographic
right with my age group and not the same
number of people and they had a good
experience
i'm going to trust them almost as if
it's like a friend giving me a personal
recommendation so
i just want to make that clear
distinction because for me those are
some of the always
the important pieces of identifying
those real pain points and i just
i just couldn't agree more with that
mindset yeah and one thing i'd layer in
as well
is everything you've said is is bang on
but then in addition those people that
are now
um almost de-risking the holiday and
looking at how can i make sure that
there's a good experience yes
previously it's about you risking the
holiday it is exactly but previously
they were pretty risky
are you before kids and all the stories
are the same right we used to travel the
world
you know we love travel we're really
passionate about culture
like you've had that experience before
you have kids and then you have kids and
it's almost like the travel world ends
and your experience of exploring the
world ends and then you basically just
make do
until your kids are old enough to do
something with
the meaningful or until they've left you
and then you end up being that sort of
like
actually my kids are at university and
now i can travel again as an adult
and i think that is such a shame
primarily for the children which is
what an amazing opportunity we have to
educate our children on diversity and
difference as they grow up
and the way that you can do that and
expand their mindset so that they are
not just stuck within the four walls
either of their house or their community
and they can see beyond that is helping
them discover
whether that's from home virtually or
whether that's actually traveling
right now that makes a lot of sense so
you know 2020 hits
traveling is halted you're running a
trip of your company you're you're
growing yet all of a sudden you have to
do some recalculation and figure out
how do you adapt as probably the
industry that was hit the hardest
and then anyone could have ever thought
so what what is your
interpretation of it as the as you know
running this company and what actions do
you have to take in order to mitigate
that
yeah so i mean it's it's been really
devastating being
um in the travel industry almost as a
newbie because i've you know my
experience
is predominantly fintech and i've come
in disrupting travel from the outside
um and just to see and so many travel
businesses over the last couple of
months
go under and and um
you know at the moment it is hugely
challenging for the industry as a whole
because when people are not traveling
you're not getting revenue through
essentially it's just firefighting it's
it's crisis management
how do i get to the next stage um
and and for us we have we've been lucky
in that
over this time we were always building a
product we were always um
going to be about how do you understand
truly understand your customer which is
in our case
families and understand their complexity
and then
match them to the best places for them
so it's those two worlds the
the traveler and the you know the the
the holiday the property and how do you
bring those two together seamlessly
um and so we've we've we've been funded
we've been going through that kind of
test and learn iterative process
um and now we're coming out of it you
know with the future in sight with
vaccinations
and you know with clear signs from the
insights that we're getting from our
partners that
travel bookings are starting to pick up
and their sentiment is increasing
um and interestingly particularly for
families so families are leading the
recovery in the uk
um out of all different traveler sets so
they are currently
the uh traveler type that's booking the
most holidays
um and so for us that's really
encouraging and i think it is back to
that point
that you know um there's almost an
intrinsic need and
that has been i think a reality that
families have realized even more which
is that you know having been cooped up
at home uh one of the ways to just uh
when you've
been cooped up is is to kind of go and
just break through the mould and explore
and i think that's going to be one of
the things that we're going to be seeing
families and all travelers do is they
can travel again
that pent up demand is is certainly
there and people will be wanting to book
um holidays um but yeah so i mean
it's uh the challenge for us really has
been the testing and learn process
because
you're not testing and learning with a
lot of people coming through your
product because you know people don't
want to book travel so we've had to be
really experimental in how we've gotten
feedback from users
how we've tested the concepts and how
we've come to a point where
we know there's product market fit 100
so you know tell me a little bit about
the customer journey
how does the you know family actually
get to the end result
of of you know booking that and
not even the booking but even the
matching process so how do you go from
now the six weeks
down to possibly even a single session
where you find the right match
yeah yeah yeah so what we do is we use
artificial intelligence machine learning
and big data to be able to understand a
family and match them to the right
property and in in detail what that is
is essentially it's a digital assistant
and we call our digital assistant sky
and we have created sky to uh
talk to families in a way that a real
travel consultant would talk to you
and so we're recreating that sort of
dialogue you get with a human being
digitally and at scale because you know
uh millions of customers can speak to
sky at the same time
um and then as they go through that
process of speaking to sky
we obviously then use all that
information uh that you know we spent
a year testing and learning on how do
you recreate that dialogue in a
meaningful way for families
and we've created a recommender engine
and the recommender engine is
fed by um our partnership with the likes
of expedia groups so we have access to
700 000
properties um and we access those 700
000 properties have all data sets and
reviews on those properties and then
we're able to
within um seconds uh
match all the information that families
have given to all the properties
uh that are available and give them a
selection of five to six matches that
are the best for their needs
that that's very very cool i i think
that what you're doing is is really
interesting and i think that
one of the most interesting pieces here
is and you said this before you're an
outsider coming in to disrupt the travel
industry
so i i'd love to hear your personal
experience coming in you know you're and
bloomberg you're in finance you work
with data and the numbers and all that
fun stuff
and you're saying you know what i'm
going to be an entrepreneur i'm going to
go to an industry that i i don't know
much about i just know my own personal
pains
and you you you become a thought leader
in that industry what is the process of
that like what how do you even get
started
and how do you know where you're
supposed to be going because it's a
whole new world
yeah and i think that's one of the
biggest pieces of advice i give when
people you know kind of ask me about my
journey
is um for me it wasn't about i want to
disrupt travel
it was actually i've experienced a pain
point
that is really significant for me and
i'm going to validate and test whether
other people have that pain point
and that was my starting point and as i
then realized that actually
um 90 of
um parents uh that i spoke to um
had exactly the same issue and those you
know 10 people that didn't have the
disposable income to pay
for travel consultants to do the work so
people that were actually you know
looking to book their own holiday all
concurred the same thing that i had the
same experience as me
and then you scale it out globally and
then i started testing um
testing the hypothesis through research
so i spent three months in the british
library
i um took out every single document i
could around travel
family travel i very quickly realized
there is basically no data on families
there's no understanding of the family
market so there's only one article in
the whole
of the british library which is from
2015 which talks in any way about
families
and on the face of it you think well you
know people aren't talking about it
maybe it's not interesting but for me i
was like that was a big aha moment i was
like
this is a this is a you know if there's
such a
a dearth of information about families
how can
uh they be serviced in a proper way
right and obviously there's a huge
opportunity there so then um
then i explored i spoke to some
investors very early on um
and um and also some financial
professionals got some
um sorry some travel traveler
professionals got some travel advisors
on board and for me it was all about
okay the first people i need in my
business because i'm coming from outside
is industry thought leaders that are
inside
um the industry at the moment and
recognizing right at the beginning that
i can come
from outside and disrupt which is a
great lens but at the same time
the travel industry has been going for
20 30 years online
and um i need to surround myself by
people that
have been there and done that and will
tell me all the pitfalls
and and that that i think was was
probably yeah
yeah that that was a good move i love
that
alexa maria 20 minutes go by very very
fast and i have the most important
question that i always have to ask
uh so you know given the you know the
great journey that you've had
the the great passion that you bring to
what you're doing i'd love to hear your
take on the three words
that you would use to describe yourself
or if i ask anybody around you how would
they describe
alexa um
yeah i think resilience i'm thinking of
what people have called me resilient
um determined um
and mission driven
there was a hyphen there i love that
alexa margaret von barker thank you so
much for joining me today thank you for
being generous with your time
i i can't wait to see travel come back i
can't wait to travel myself i can't wait
to see
you know families use tripper brood to
travel
and i think that what you're doing is
really is really fantastic it's really
smart i think there's
a definitely a huge market for this and
i think more importantly you're you're
making
uh you're making their their travel just
much much more fun and i think that you
know i'm seeing some young families
around me as i'm getting older and
and i see the challenges and i see how
how difficult it is it isn't just you
know
and again finding like a fun restaurant
or finding the the best hotel to use but
it really is
you know the make or break between
having a successful time with your
family
uh which has a lot of other implications
obviously as well so thank you for the
time
and uh and stay safe and stay healthy
thank you you
too take care bye thank you